[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIRK LOMBARD: So
let's do that one.
This is a famous one,
especially if you're in Ireland.
And it's really what
I am at this point,
well, beyond going out
to catch my own dinner,
I am a fishmonger.
I have to accept that
that's what I am.
I'm a fisherman too, but
I'm mostly a fish monger.
This book, however, is about
how to catch your own fish.
But there's a lot of
songs about fisherman,
but there's only like two
or three about fishmongers.
So here's one.
[SINGING "MOLLY MALONE"]
[APPLAUSE]
You see, the real
reason that we do
that is just it loosens
me up, and then it's
kind of nice to
start with clapping.
Whether I end with clapping
or not is a whole other issue.
Well here's my book.
And I'm supposed to talk
about my book today.
And run a business
called Sea Forager.
Many of you may
know this already,
but I'm just going to
backtrack a little bit.
And Sea Forager
is the culmination
of sort of my crazy
misspent life walking
the intertidal
zone of this area.
The intertidal zone
is a fancy term
for that area between
high tide and low tide.
That's kind of my zone.
There's a famous book about the
intertidal zone of California
called "Between Pacific Tides."
Raise your hand if you've
heard of this book?
Oh great, that's excellent.
It just makes me feel smarter
than you, or more nerdy,
really.
"Between Pacific Tides"
was written by a biologist
by the name of Doc
or Ed Ricketts.
Ed Ricketts was the
central character
in Steinbeck's "Cannery Row,"
and was also Steinbeck's best
friend, John
Steinbeck's best friend.
And they wrote a
little book called
"The Log Book of
the Sea of Cortez,"
which is a wonderful
sort of travelogue
of their experiences
in the intertidal zone,
that area between high tide and
low tide, along the California
coast all the way down to Baja.
And it's kind of a cool place.
I didn't actually mean
to do this, but why not?
That book, "Between Pacific
Tides," sort of made
the California intertidal zone,
put it on the map, so to speak.
It's sort of a tome
of marine biology.
So if you go to Humboldt
State or wherever,
you can get a good
degree in marine biology,
and you'll know all about
"Between Pacific Tides."
And if you get a first
edition copy of that book,
you'll notice it looks-- sort
of the aesthetic of the cover
is not dissimilar to this.
And that's not an accident.
My book is a foraging
and fishing guide.
It is not a textbook
of marine biology.
This is filled with
humorous haikus and poems
and funny anecdotes about
some of the strange things
that I've eaten and
hunted on the shoreline.
In other words, it's
not a piece of science.
And yet there's some good
scientific data in here,
if you are interested in that.
But I was so influenced by that
book "Between Pacific Tides"
and by its writer,
Doc Ricketts, who's
one of the great eccentrics
of the California shores.
He tragically died at
the age of, I think,
38 or something, so very young.
He was hit by a train.
And it took him three days
to die after getting run over
by a train.
And John Steinbeck
said rather famously--
they were like best
friends, inseparable.
And Steinbeck, who
was just heartbroken
by this, he said, "Well,
the only thing that could
have killed Ed was a train.
And it took three days at that."
In any case, when I got my
buddy Leighton to do all the art
work.
And if you just look through
this, and you kind of just,
boop, boop, boop,
I think you'll see
that the detail and sort
of the humor come through.
So if you look at the
[INAUDIBLE] page on page 85,
you'll see that the
thing that he always
puts in the background
of an image,
so that you can see the size,
is some form of detritus
from our American civilization.
So if you look in
the bait section,
you'll see under the--
innkeeper warm on 81, a rather
adult illustration.
Yeah, because the
fat innkeeper one
is also called the penis
fish, by various cultures.
And, well, you can see that
there is a spent condom wrapper
there to illustrate the size.
And then if you
look at page 168--
I just thumbed through there--
we were singing about cockles
and mussels, and we got all
kinds of cockles and mussels
in this book if you're
interested in those things.
We have cockles in California.
There's cockles that
everybody calls cockles,
and then there's real cockles.
We talk about that later.
But if you look on
page 168, you'll
see the size of the thing
that he put for scale here
is a cigarette butt.
So I wanted it to sort of
have this feeling of being
part of the modern world.
And that's how Leighton
chose to do that.
But Leighton, the
illustrator of this book,
is just somebody I've
known a long time
and I've just always
loved his little drawings,
and I wanted to
collaborate with him.
And so the publisher, when
they saw a few of his drawings,
they immediately hired
him on, and paid him
to do all of the illustrations.
But he didn't just want
to do illustrations.
He wanted to have a hand
in the design of the book.
And so he called me
one day, after he had
been hired on to the project.
And we were both very happy.
And he said, Kirk, "I don't just
want to do the illustrations.
I want to have some say
in the font and the color
and the cover and
the back cover.
I don't want them just to
take it and do their thing.
I want to have some input."
I said, "Well, you've
gotta talk to the designer.
I'm not sure she's
open to that."
As it turns out, she
was open to that,
and actually did a great job.
But in any case, the
point being that while I
was talking to Leighton,
and he was telling me
that he had a larger
goal, he said, "So,
just speaking
aesthetically, what do you
want this book to look like?"
And I said, "Well,
there's a book,
the first edition of this
very famous marine biology
tome that all fish geeks
know all about this book
or all vertebrate geeks
know about this book."
And I just assumed
that Leighton would not
know this book because he's
not an outdoorsman kind of guy.
He's more of just a
brilliantly talented artist,
but I don't think of
him as a person who
forages in the intertidal zone.
So I didn't think he would know
about "Between Pacific Tides."
And I said, "Well, the name of
the book is 'Between Pacific
Tides.' And if you get a first
edition copy, I'll pay for it.
I just want you to look at it
so you get a sense of the feel
and the look of that book."
And he goes, "That's strange,
because I'm holding a first
edition copy of 'Between Pacific
Tides.' I've had it for, like,
my entire life.
It's like 35 years old,"
or however old Leighton is.
"And it was sitting
right here on my desk.
And that's actually
why I was calling you.
I wanted to know if you wanted
the book to kind of look
like that."
And it was one of those
moments of synchronicity.
But it gets weirder.
And I said, "So Leighton,
you're not a forager.
You're not a fisherman and
you're not a marine biologist.
Why do you have that book?
And why do you have a
first edition copy of it?"
And he said, "Well, I've been
meaning to tell you this,
but did you know that my
grandfather, Richie Lovejoy,
did all of the illustrations for
'Between Pacific Tides?' I said
"No, I had no idea," which
is just really bizarre.
And you know, when
things come together
like that-- it was
sort of at that moment
that-- I knew from the
start that Leighton
was the guy for the job.
But then that just kind
of cemented the deal.
And so I gave Leighton,
in the back of the book,
there's a little-- I love his--
he always remains incognito.
He did a little sketch
in the back of the book,
and he didn't want
our full visages.
If you go back to page
257, he put a catfish
in front of his face.
Of course that catfish,
in Vietnam or somewhere
in Southeast Asia, that catfish
is referred to as a lele.
And that happens to be
Leighton's nickname.
But on the last couple
pages, page 258, 259,
I let Leighton tell the story
of his grandfather Richie
Lovejoy, who was best friends
with Ed Ricketts and John
Steinbeck.
I want you to know that I'm
more proud of the editing
that I did on these--
because this was six pages.
Leighton is a little verbose.
I cut him down to
a page and a half.
I'm very proud of that.
And he would be
happy about that too,
because he kind of went
off on some tangents.
He doesn't know
this, so hopefully he
won't see this video.
Hi Leigh.
Anyway, so blah, blah,
blah, so here's my book.
And this book is basically a
coming together of the walking
tours that I do
around San Francisco
where I take people out.
I took a bunch of
Google people out once,
right across the street
on the Embarcadero.
Is that there?
It's there, right?
And like when you go and
you sit at the counter
where I just ate lunch,
and you look down,
that's where I did my
walking tour for you guys.
And then along
that same shoreline
I do herring tours
in the winter,
because that whole
shoreline just becomes
infested with Pacific herring.
When they spawn, they
spawn right there,
and armed with a casting net,
you can throw a casting net
and get your supply of
herring for the year.
Most people, that would
be like three pounds.
That's not mine.
But in one throw when
you're fishing for herring,
you can you get 25 pounds
if they're really spawning.
And it's just amazing.
You can do that right here.
As I discussed in the book, when
you're eating small schooling
fish that aren't eating in
the area where you catch them,
the health risks are minimal.
Herring don't live long enough
to bioaccumulate toxins.
So I'm just sort of
thinking ahead here, I'm
talking about catching
herring, getting
your supply for the year.
And I know you guys are
thinking, from there?
But again, this is a
small schooling fish
that lives up to
maybe five years,
doesn't have time to
bioaccumulate toxins.
So they're super high in omega
3s and all the good things
that a fish has.
Just in the winter, it's just
insane the amounts of herring.
I mean literally, you
take a little net,
you throw it in the
water, you pull it up,
and there's 25 pounds
of flapping fish.
I used to have a
video of myself,
and I showed you guys
that one of my talks here.
I held up the cell and everybody
was just-- because it's
right by the arrow,
the bow and arrow,
like right on the other side of
that right where the water is
just-- throwing that in
the water in the winter,
on certain days.
Anyway, I don't know why
I'm going there, but--
I do these tours.
And this was the
culmination of all the stuff
I talk about on my tours, plus
little anecdotes and things.
One of my favorite chapters
to read from in here
is my bait chapter.
And there's a reason for that.
I tend to notice
that most books that
talk-- most books
about fishing, that
mention fishing in any way--
there's a lot more than fishing
in here.
There's sea weeds and clams
and mussels and everything.
But there's a lot of
fish talk in here.
And most books that
talk about fishing,
I just find them
terribly boring,
because it's usually about how
do you catch the biggest fish.
And this goes for most fishing
websites and most fishing blogs
and fishing videos on YouTube.
It's, OK, this guy's going to
show us the big fish, which
is compensation usually
for something else,
or I should say a lack of
something else, in my opinion.
In any case, I wanted
to give a whole chapter
to the little fish that people
use for bait in our area.
And one of those fish is
a remarkable toadfish.
I guess they're called toadfish
because they have-- well they
look kind of like a toad.
They have these little
bumps on their eyes
and they've got an
ugly face like a toad.
But they have this other
salient characteristic
that toads and frogs have,
which is that they sing.
And this singing fish is
called the plainfin midshipman.
And it strikes me as
bizarre, even now,
having talked about this
fish ad infinitum, all
of these little mud
dwelling little fish-- now
this guy's about the size
of this book, a big one.
And there's a
whole bunch of them
that live in the same area
that look kind of similar
and live in the mud.
And you could turn a rock over
at low tide in San Francisco
Bay in the summer, you'll
find these little fish.
And they're all little
ugly, but kind of cute,
mud dwelling monster looking
fish with totally weird names.
The one that I'm
going to talk about
is called the
plainfin midshipman.
But the fish that you
often find right next to it
is called longjawed
mudsucker, which I just
find that is such a great name.
It's like something that
you would yell at someone
you don't like.
But it's a beautiful
little fish.
It used to be the
dominant mudsucker.
It's such a dubious distinction.
It was at one time the dominant
mudsucker of our region,
but it's been replaced by an
invasive goby from Tokyo Bay
called the yellowfin goby, which
in Japan is called the haze
or the "haz-ay."
I don't know how
to pronounce it.
It's spelled H-A-Z-E.
And they have
little charter boats
that go out into
Tokyo Bay and catch
this fish as a targeted
fish that people eat.
No one that I know of
in San Francisco Bay
has ever eaten one of
these, but we have them
here now because they
travel in ballast water.
And then when the
big tankers come in,
they dump the ballast water.
And now we have
this other species
called the yellowfin
goby, which has
displaced our lovely longjaw
mudsucker because it's
more adaptable.
So there's the longjaw
mudsucker, the plainfin
midshipman.
And then there's a thing
called the Pacific staghorn
sculpin, which is named for the
opercular spine that comes out
of its gill, has little
notches on the side of it
that some biologist
with a microscope
decided looked like
the antlers of a stag.
So they called it the
Pacific staghorn sculpin.
And these are all
fish that at low tide
if you went down there
and turned over rocks
you would find.
And then the last
one, of course,
has the best name
of all, and that
is the sarcastic fringehead.
And the sarcastic
fringehead, I really--
you guys are all,
I know, eminently
capable of doing this.
Go to YouTube and do a search
for mating ritual or mating
fight of the
sarcastic fringehead.
You will not be disappointed.
The head of this fish, its
mouth is proportionately,
I think, larger than the
proportionate body size
to mouth ratio of any species.
So when it fights,
it unfurls the mouth.
So you have this little fish
that's got a body this long
and a head that's like that.
It's insane.
It's just designed by evolution
to just freak people out
to make them laugh.
In any case, back to the point.
My little fish that
I want to talk about
is called the
plainfin midshipman.
And it's got all
these great talents.
I'm going to go through
them real quickly
and then I'm going
to read the story.
It's a page and a half.
Among the many talents is that
singing that I talked about.
But it also has this
fish, the plainfin,
he has spots all over
the sides and belly.
And when it's been eating a
certain type of phytoplankton,
the spots light up bright
blue like your shirt,
except iridescent.
And they blink like
a Christmas tree.
So it's a humming fish that
lights up with blue spots.
It also has poison in its
mucus around its spines
so that if you get
jabbed with it,
your thumbs-- your fingers
kind of blow up like sausages.
And beyond that, it also
has the unique ability
to survive an incredibly wide
ranging series of depths.
So it lives offshore
in 3,000 feet of water,
and then when it's
time for spawning
it comes all the way
into San Francisco Bay
and goes down to Candlestick
Park in the toxic mud
flats and digs under a rock
in three inches of water.
And the female lays
her little golden eggs
on the ceiling, if you will,
of the rock that she goes in.
And she lays the eggs.
And then the male comes
in in a successive wave.
And the male comes in and
goes into that burrow.
And she's like sitting there.
And the first male comes
in. "She's like get away,"
bap, bap, bap.
And she knocks him
away and he leaves.
And then the male that
she's looking for,
he comes in the hole, and
she goes, "Oh, OK, come in."
And then she goes,
"They're my eggs."
She doesn't really
speak like this.
I'm anthropomorphizing the fish.
And so she lets this male in.
And the male, you know,
he's like OK, this is it.
This is where I'm going
to be for a while.
And then she takes
off and she goes
and gets nice and big and fat
so that maybe at some point
she can make more eggs.
And she goes out every day
and she forages and eats.
Meanwhile, the male
that she's agreed upon,
well he gets to spritz
those eggs with his seed.
And then his job for the rest
of the summer is to sit there.
Every single time a
little piece of mud lands
on one of those eggs,
he picks it off.
And he keeps them
perfectly clean.
And if a male comes in to
try to spritz those eggs,
he chases the male away,
unless it's the type two male.
The type two male is the beta
male of the plainfin midshipman
population.
And the type two male
impersonates a female,
and then goes into
the same hole.
And when the guard, the male
who's guarding those eggs,
he sees the female
come in, he thinks,
well maybe she'll plant
some more eggs on it
to do the thing.
So I won't chase her away.
And he's like, OK, you
can stay over there.
And he kind of watches her.
And then when he's
not looking, basically
that female
impersonator, who has
gigantic testes compared to the
other one-- I don't know why.
But the invader, the type
two male, suddenly goes over
and he spritz the eggs.
So any eggs that weren't
fertilized by the first one
get fertilized by that one.
And so that's how the
beta male keeps his genes
in the population.
I know too much about this
species to speak about it
for less than 20 minutes.
In any case, I have now
told you everything you
need to know about this fish.
The way we catch them as
fishermen, and the reason we
use them, we use them for
bait because you take a hook,
big hook, and you stick
it through his nose,
and you throw the
midshipman out there,
and they're so tough
they don't die.
So you can fish with one for
hours and hours and hours.
Even when they die, they
release some kind of ooze
that fish really like to eat.
So what fishermen look
for in a live bait
is something that
wriggles and stays
alive on the hook
for a long time.
And this has always struck
me as uniquely tragic,
to value an animal for how
wonderfully it suffers.
And so I just thought
that no one else
is going to write
this chapter singing
the praises of this little
fish, so I'm going to do it.
And I call this little piece,
that's in the back of my book--
and it's, I think,
representative of sort
of my feeling about the book.
There's a lot of little pieces
that are kind of like this.
I try to take a
different look at things.
This little thing is
called, "The death
song of the toadfishes."
"I'm not sure why,
but leopard sharks--"
leopard sharks are very common
mud-dwelling, bottom-dwelling
sand shark type of thing
that lives out in the Bay.
They're not like a piscivorous
shark with big teeth.
They're a sluggish
bottom dweller.
"I'm not sure why, but leopard
sharks really like midshipman.
And for a halibut or anything
else to take your offering
of one, it's going
to have to get
in line behind every leopard
shark inhabiting the spot
where you're fishing.
My last time out on
my kayak, I caught
about a half a dozen sharks
on a single plainfin.
He couldn't seem to stay in
the water for five minutes
before a leopard shark would
slam him and start dragging me
into the shipping lanes.
And they seemed to
like him better dead
and chewed than
alive and squirming.
As anyone who kayak fishes
can confirm however--
as anyone who kayak
fishes can confirm,
however fun leopard
sharks are to fight,
they are a royal pain
in the arse to unhook,
especially the big
ones on a windy day
with a strong outgoing tide
on a 10 foot sit on top kayak.
But the strange thing
was, everywhere I
went that day it was the
same-- along rocky shoreline,
under the peers, out
in the open water,
leopard shark after leopard
shark after leopard shark.
It was as if they
were following me.
They were.
After fishing for two hours
with that one midshipman,
I pulled in my live bait bucket,
which usually trails behind me
on a rope as I
drift, and decided
to swap out my wildly
popular shredded bait fish
for a new live one.
I placed the bucket
on the kayak,
cleaned the grim remnants
of the first midshipman off
of my hook, and suddenly noticed
that the boat was buzzing.
The midshipman, their nests
destroyed, their eggs uprooted,
their lives about to be
forfeit to the uncaring
jaws of a sluggish bottom
dweller, were singing.
I held the bucket to my ear.
What was this song?
How often had they sung it?
In the depths of the sea,
in the polluted sluices
of Stege Marsh, in the
yuppie flats of Tiburon,
was it their national anthem,
their rembetika, their blues?
After a few moments, I realized
what I was listening to.
It was the death song
of the toadfishes.
I sat there for a while staring
out at the container ships,
listening to this melancholy,
monotonous death song, feeling,
I suppose, not unlike the
Grinch staring down on Whoville
before his yuletide
transformation.
After a few gut
wrenching moments,
my callous fisherman's
heart swelled
into thrice its usual size.
I paddled to shore and dumped
the remaining midshipman
back into the turbid waters
from whence they came.
I have little doubt
that a sizable school
of leopard sharks had been
following my kayak all day.
It was not a bait bucket but
a leopard shark dinner bell
that I'd been
dragging behind me.
I guess every fisherman
has his weakness,
his figurative kryptonite.
But how can one justify
destroying their nests
and skewering their
remarkable little bodies just
to waste them on leopard sharks?
If you find that they're a great
halibut bait or good for lings
or stripers or sea bass, maybe.
But leopard sharks?
Thanks.
I'll stick to squid.
Honestly I think
the problem here
is that I know too much
about these little buggers
to use them for bait.
And now, with any luck, so you."
And then I wrote a haiku,
because as you can tell,
I'm kind of into this fish.
And there's a footnote here.
I should read the footnote.
You know there's a great
masterpiece of fiction
called "The Third Policeman."
I don't expect anyone other than
me and like 16 other people who
have read this book.
It's called "The
Third Policeman."
It's by an Irish
writer by the name
of Flann O'Brien who wrote
under the pseudonym Myles
na gCopaleen, if you want
to look up his other work.
But this Irish
writer, Flann O'Brien,
wrote a brilliant thing
called "The Third Policeman,"
absolutely insane book.
And one of the characters in the
book talks through footnotes.
And it's so insane that you'll
have these moments where
there's a sentence, and
then nine pages of footnote
as this character sort
of expresses himself.
And I found it to be such
a brilliant and humorous
little thing in a book to
have these crazy footnotes.
So I put a lot of crazy
footnotes in my book
because I'm sort of
a disciple-- well,
I'm a worshipper of that writer.
And so for people who are like,
what's with all the footnotes
here?
And I'm, well, I like footnotes.
I find them funny.
In any case, my haiku is-- and
please, count the syllables.
Last time I did this,
somebody counted the syllables
while I was doing it.
Haiku number 214.
That doesn't mean there's
214 haikus in this book,
God forbid.
That's just the number that
this was for me personally.
Haiku number 214.
"Plainfin midshipman,
most talented of fishes.
Why not leave them be?"
And then I wrote
here under where--
I have the sentence
where I said, "Thanks,
I'll stick to
squid," in reference
to not using
midshipman for bait.
I just thought
this was relevant.
Oh what did I say--
stripers, leopard sharks.
"Thanks, I'll stick to squid.
I'm sure someone
out there is going
to point out the remarkable
life story of the squid.
But alas, every species on
our fair planet is remarkable.
One has to pick and
choose I suppose.
For me, the midshipman
gets a pass.
For you, it might be octopus
or anchovies or, I don't know,
fat innkeeper worms."
That's the penis fish
I referred to earlier.
"In any case, the
important thing
is to remember that
they're all remarkable,
even the ones we use for bait."
And you'll notice, for those of
you who actually have the book,
on page 66-- and this
will be the last thing
I say about this lovely fish.
On page 66, my buddy
Leighton-- years ago,
I wanted to do a "Toxic
Avenger" style comic book.
It was my idea to write
it and have Leighton
do all the illustrations.
And so we planned it out.
And you know how
like With Spider-Man
and I think Fantastic Four,
and most of these early '60s
superheroes, early
'70s, early '60s,
because like Thor I think-- well
maybe not so much with Thor.
But I'm really geeking
myself right now with this.
But have you noticed
that all of those guys
got their superpowers
because of gamma rays?
Spider-Man got it
because a gamma
ray infected spider bit him,
transferred the power, right?
I thought, well, the
plainfin midshipman,
if there was nuclear
residue in the mud,
it might have become some
kind of crazy superhero,
Toxic Avenger style superhero.
So the idea was that
he would flash people
with his photophores
and then buzz them
to death with his
singing, because they
seem kind of like [GRUNTING].
It's like it's like the
Mongolian tuvan throat singing.
I was supposed to
do that earlier.
I didn't do that.
And so there it is.
And you can see
that picture there
on page 66, a good number
for the midshipman.
Anyway, I could go
on and on and on,
but are there any questions?
You don't have to
have questions.
You can ask me anything, really.
But that's OK if
you don't want to.
I'll just keep going.
And please, if it's getting
to the end of your lunch break
or whatever, don't feel shy.
If you have to go,
you have to go.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Song you sang earlier,
why does it have to be sad?
KIRK LOMBARD: Why does it what?
AUDIENCE: Why does it
have to be a sad song?
KIRK LOMBARD: Well,
because she died.
But you know, she died, but
then she came back as a ghost.
So it's not that bad I guess.
There's some resurrection
involved, I guess.
I don't think there's a
lost verse to that song.
Do you know of a lost verse
where she comes back to life
and everybody's happy?
Well you know, Molly
Malone considered
to be-- so anyone
been to Dublin here?
Anyone seen the statue?
There's a Molly Malone
statue in Dublin.
And unfortunately-- it's
a really nice statue
and she's very
well proportioned.
But people take-- it's
like they rub her boobies.
So she's got these two
bright brass boobs,
because everybody rubs them.
At least that's how it
was when I was there.
But oh, Molly Malone
was supposedly
not just a fishmonger,
she was a streetwalker.
AUDIENCE: I thought that
was a fictitious character.
KIRK LOMBARD: No, I
think-- it is probably
a fictitious character.
But the legend goes that she
also had ulterior-- well,
not ulterior, but rather
alternative sources of income,
as many young lasses had
to do in those bleak times.
I think that the idea was
that that's what killed her,
some disease.
Now I don't know where.
You'll have to google this.
It's so refreshing
that none of you
are doing that to
me while I speak,
because there's always
that fear, right,
especially for somebody like
me who lives in tall tales.
In any case--
AUDIENCE: What about herring?
KIRK LOMBARD: What about it?
AUDIENCE: Can we
catch it around here.
KIRK LOMBARD: OK, now who
was listening earlier?
Can we catch
herring around here?
Raise your hand if you say yes.
And raise your hand if you say
no, because there are no nos.
There's just some neutrals.
OK, what time of year-- I
mentioned it several times--
will you be able to look
for herring in the water
right across the street?
AUDIENCE: Winter.
KIRK LOMBARD: Right.
So for those of you
who-- raise your hand
if you weren't even aware that
there is herring in the bay?
Right, actually most
people are that way.
It's very strange
to someone like me
who spends so much time around
the water and in the water.
But the general populace of San
Francisco is unaware of this.
And it's not your fault. It's
that herring-- there is really
very little demand for small
fish in mainstream American
seafood consumption.
So you go to a market,
you're very rarely
going to see herring unless you
go at the beginning of herring
season to Chinatown.
In some of the
live markets there
you'll see herring
on the shelves.
And that's about it as
far as getting them.
So you have to catch them
if you want to eat them.
And it's so much fun.
In fact, I've brought a lot
of people out to do this.
And they go and they get their
license and they come out,
and most of them are people
who have never fished before.
And they get into the
process of catching herring.
And then before they
know it, they've
got 65 pounds of herring.
Now it takes maybe five
hours to clean 25 pounds.
So 65 pounds, you're looking
at like, 12-- my math is off.
But you're looking at a
full day of scaling fish
and gutting them and
cutting their heads off.
So I always tell people,
if you do get into this,
just be advised,
it's a lot of fun
and you're going to want to keep
going, and there's no limit.
There's no sport limit on them.
You can catch as
many as you want.
So just be advised, you've
got a lot of work ahead of you
if you take more
than five pounds.
But it's so much fun.
I wish I had my little video.
I would show you, right there,
me standing right there.
You know that little
pier that goes out
and it's got the silver
swivel seats, right next
to the metal pier?
It's right in that
corner, right there,
between that and the
old bus station there.
Anyway, the herring is--
what can I say really?
It's a miracle
that it's even here
when we consider that 2/3
of the original shoreline--
well, 2/3, it's more 2/3
of the original shoreline
of the entire San Francisco
Bay has been filled in.
And this is the fish that
spawns on the shoreline.
Most of the eelgrass beds
where they spawn traditionally
are gone.
They're totally gone.
So what did this little
guy do, this little fish?
I say guy.
I keep male-izing the fish,
but that's not really true.
The males and the
females, what did they
do in order to survive?
Instead of going and seeing
the loss of their eelgrass beds
and then dying out,
they just decided
to lay their eggs
in other places.
And that's an incredible
ability to adapt.
So in the old days where they
used to spawn only on eelgrass,
now they spawn underneath boats
and along rocks and on seaweed,
anywhere.
I think that in their
little herring brains,
the thing they would
love more than anything
is an entire shoreline
filled with the eelgrass,
but they don't
have that anymore.
And they adapted.
And so like last year,
the spawning biomass
of little Pacific herring
inside San Francisco Bay
was estimated somewhere
around 15,000 tons-- 15, yeah.
So that's a lot of fish.
And that's the lowest
it's been in many years.
In the last 10 years,
it's gone as high
as 60,000 to 70,000 tons,
inside San Francisco Bay.
That's how many are in there.
Really, even if you're not
going to go out and get
all excited about
eating a little fish--
I think you should
get excited about it.
But even if you're
not going to, what
goes on along the shoreline when
there's a herring spawn-- it's
so bizarre to me to walk
down the Embarcadero
when the herring are lighting
up the whole shoreline,
and you'll see like
25 seals in the water.
And you'll see a
flock of cormorants
that's got at least 8,000 birds
in it going through the water.
And you'll see pelican after
pelican through, foo, foo, foo,
foo, just dropping
out of the sky.
I've even seen, in San
Francisco Bay, an osprey,
in the bay, grabbing
herring out the water.
I mean, whales will come
in as far as Alcatraz,
because they smell it and
they want to get in on it.
But then they start moving
in towards the shoreline
and, eh, there's cables
and sewer lines and ships.
I'm out here.
But the abundance of animal
life, of nature-- and this
is in the middle of a city.
In my experience,
I've not experienced--
I've never really
seen anything quite
like-- in an urban context.
I grew up in New York.
And we have eels under the
peers and bluefish and stuff
like that.
But a Herring spawn in the
middle of a major urban center,
I can't think of that.
I mean, maybe in Vancouver or
something-- not even there.
And so even if you're not
interested in eating them
or using them for bait-- they're
great bait for everything--
just to go down to the bay
when it's happening and stand
there--
I mean, last year
or two years ago
I did a tour for
the Audubon people.
And there's a whole contingent.
So the Audubon people who
are like insane bird nerds,
like out of control.
That's their life is
like looking at birds.
Maybe some of you are birders
or amateur ornithologists,
I don't know.
But then there's the bird nerds
that can identify seagulls.
Now this is like bordering
on some kind of a psychosis,
because to the average
eye, seagulls really
look a lot alike.
But you'll see like a little bit
of different type of grayness
in some of the wings and the
size is a little different.
And sometimes they
have a red bill
and sometimes they
have a yellow bill.
But they really
look a lot alike.
But the variety of
seagulls, if this
is some kind of
enticement to you,
is supposedly
insane during-- it's
really hard to get people
excited about this.
But just to go down and
see 85,000 seagulls--
that's what they estimated.
There were 85,000 seagulls
along the shoreline in Tiburon
last year.
But it's the same thing
on the Embarcadero.
And it's just gorgeous
and beautiful.
We have a commercial
fishery for them in the bay.
One of my good buddies is a
commercial herring fisherman.
And they use gill nets.
And they set the gill nets
up next to the shoreline
where they think the herring
are about to move in and lay
their eggs.
So when the herring move
in to lay their eggs,
they hit the gill net
and they get stuck.
And then the guys pull
them out by the thousands.
A good day, they'll
get 20 tons in one day.
And the reason we're not
so concerned about that
is that they're
only fishing a total
of 5% of the total
biomass of the species.
So last year the biomass
was 15-- what did I say,
15,000 tons?
So they're only
fishing 5% of that,
which is not considered to
have a great toll on the fish.
Is that enough on
the herring bit?
AUDIENCE: That was great.
Makes me hungry.
What about, for the
book, is [INAUDIBLE]?
KIRK LOMBARD: So the
question is-- and thanks
for asking that-- if somebody
has never really gone
out fishing or foraging
before, what are
the most basic things in here?
Well I go over the
nuances of clamming.
And you've got some great
potential spots for clams
in our region of California.
You have to drive to some of
them to get to the clean ones.
I mean there's hella clams
in San Francisco Bay,
but no one in their right
mind would eat them,
because clams live a relatively
long time and they don't move.
So whatever's in
the water in that
spot is going to be in
you if you eat that clam.
So you want to go up the coast.
There's a couple places down
the coast you can go to.
I try not to burn
locations, but it's
a Google search away finding
the good locations for clamming
and picking mussels.
So that's one place
that all you need
is a recreational
sport fishing license.
And you can take this book
and it will really help you.
And then seaweed, I cover
all the basic seaweeds
along our shoreline.
Again, you should
get a fishing license
if you're going to do seaweed.
A lot of people think
they don't need it,
but you should have that.
It's like $50, and it's good for
the year in which you buy it.
So if you buy it now, it's
only good till December 31.
Well I feel like
I'm back in my day.
I used to work for the fish
and game department explaining
all the rules and regulations.
And I'm back there now.
But in any case, yes, and so
the seaweeds and the clams.
Some of the fishing stuff, if
you have some basis in fishing,
I think you'll be fine.
But if you have no basis
at all in catching fish,
like you've never gone
like this, if you've never
done that before, then there's
a whole chapter on poke poling.
Poke poling is a
technique that was
used by Native Americans
along this coast for thousands
of years, I think, at least.
And you can catch a lot of
fish by just taking a stick.
Now the modern
adaptation of this stick
is you take the stick, you take
a wire hanger from your closet.
You unravel it, put a
little loop in the end,
tie some line onto it,
put a hook on the line.
So you've got a stick.
Bamboo is great, a bamboo
stick, wire hanger,
loop in the wire
hanger at the bottom.
Wire hanger is taped.
So stick, tape, wire
hanger, loop, line, hook.
Onto that hook, put a
little piece of squid.
Go to any fish market in the Bay
Area and buy a pound of squid
for $2.69.
And then walk out at low tide.
And everywhere you see a
rock that comes together
with another rock or a
hole or a crack, stick
that gently into the--
the sexual innuendo here
is through the roof.
You stick your
stick into the hole,
and then as you go like this
and you kind of, like, do this,
the fish that live in the
holes between the rocks
will come up and bite the
hook and you pull them out
of the hole.
And that requires none
of this, [WHOOSH].
And it's a very good way to
go along the California coast
and get your own fish.
So hopefully that
answers your question.
And that's a very
wonderful technique
for beginning fishermen to use,
because you'll catch stuff.
And all you have to do
is tie a couple of knots.
And that's it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
So this will cover what
you do with the fish
after you catch it if you've
never gutted or cleaned
or anything.
KIRK LOMBARD: So there's
a little bit on cleaning.
And there's a lot on fish prep.
And there's a whole section
on how to prep small fish.
And I mean as far
as cleaning a fish,
there's like 5 million videos.
And I really felt that
those are so much more
useful than anything
I'm going to write.
And also like writing
that, it's so simple,
and yet it's just not the
kind of writing I like to do.
So I would refer you to YouTube
for actually cleaning big fish.
For cleaning small fish, I
have all kinds of techniques
that I wrote in here,
which is probably
where you're going to be anyway
if you're just starting out.
Also the thing is full recipes.
So every little section has
recipes, most of them written
by the lady in the corner.
AUDIENCE: Another question.
you and me
KIRK LOMBARD: Well you
know, we don't have lobster
in this area of California.
And this is the "Guide to the
Northern California Coast."
The only lobster--
AUDIENCE: I've seen
lobster diving.
KIRK LOMBARD: You've seen them
because-- because of El Nino,
we had a few lobsters
that were caught off
of Pacifica last year.
And sometimes they'll see them.
But if you're to be a lobster
diver in Northern California,
you're in for a lot
of empty buckets.
AUDIENCE: More Southern
California though.
KIRK LOMBARD: Oh, Southern
California's where they live.
They only came up here
over the last two years.
There's been a few stragglers.
There was a guy on one of the
big fishing websites who posted
a picture of himself with two.
But I mean, that's insane.
And he got them at Lindamar.
I mean, everybody-- so that
just went around all the fishing
circles, and everybody
was like, what?
There's a few things like that.
Like lately last couple years
there's been bonito up here,
and that's not
typically a fish we get.
But that's because
of El Nino, we
got a lot of these warm
water animals up here.
Our water is really cold.
Spearfishing I didn't
get into too much here,
but I did get into
diving for rock scallops.
So if there's one thing
that's really, really
awesome to go risk your
life for, is rock scallops.
I mean, they're just the
most delicious thing.
AUDIENCE: Is that
the same as abalone?
KIRK LOMBARD: No.
Well, I got into the
diving a little bit
on the abalone section
too, more about
how easy it is to kill
yourself when you do it,
which almost happened to me.
I wrote a whole thing about-- my
first abalone dive, I was new.
My buddy took me out.
And we went in and the
whole time I'm out there,
I'm just like, man,
this is just sketchy.
I just know this is sketchy.
There's seals everywhere.
And he's like, "You
don't have to worry
about seals everywhere.
What you got to worry about is
when they're out of the water."
Literally 15 minutes later,
he's got his abalones,
I'm still half drowning
trying to get the abalone
to come up to the surface.
All the seals are sitting on
the rocks, every one of them.
There wasn't a single
one in the water.
And his boat has
drifted 100 yards away.
And I'm stuck in the
middle of this cove.
And I start going like
this and he's waving back.
He's not moving the boat.
So I just-- I was like, OK.
I got a flash.
An abalone iron's
made out of steel,
and it's flashing in the water.
I got my big rubber thing.
I got the thing
that measures it.
That's flashing in the water.
So flashing is something
that sharks really like.
I had to start swimming.
I'm like fuck this, I'm
going to do a Michael Phelps.
I'm going to beat all
the known records man.
I'm like, joosh, joosh.
I get all the way
back to the boat.
I'm like totally tired.
I'm like, "You asshole.
I can't believe you.
Couldn't you come over?"
And he's like, "I don't know.
There's some fish biting here."
He's fishing.
I put my arm over the side
of the-- it's a Zodiac.
We're in a 10 foot
inflatable Zodiac,
which those are pretty rugged
boats, but 10 feet or 12 feet
or something.
And I put my arm over.
I'm like trying to get up.
I'm like ugh.
I'm like, this is the
moment right here, right,
because I got all
this stuff dangling.
I have all my gear
dangling around my belt,
you know, my legs
flapping in the water.
It was like, this is where
he's going to freaking get me.
Finally I get out of the water.
I'm like OK.
Finally I'm in the boat.
And I look over at my
friend, and he's got his rod.
And he's like, "Oh
man, I got one on,"
because he was fishing
while I was swimming.
And I looked kind of over,
and the water's very clear.
And it's a lingcod.
I can see that, and it's small.
We call those shakers because
you shake them off the hook
because they're so small.
But he's bringing it up.
And I'm kind of looking
at it in the water.
And all of a sudden, underneath
the fish, there's just this,
whoosh.
Like the whole color of
the water just changed.
And it went, whoosh.
And we both went, "What
the fuck was that?"
And he's like--
he's looking down.
He's like, huh?
And he starts
reeling up like this.
And then just out
of nowhere, man, I
don't even know where
this thing came from.
There's a 12 foot
great white shark
coming up underneath this
fish with its mouth like this.
And we're in this
little fricking boat.
Dude, I'm sitting like
this, and it's there.
Like if I wanted to put
my arm down its mouth
for some insane reason,
I could have done that.
I just kind of
looked over the side.
I still had one of
my flippers on man.
I'm like one flipper
on, one flipper off.
And then I just
started screaming.
And my friend, you know, he's
sort of an unorthodox guy.
So my feeling, at that
moment, the thing's
coming up after the
fish that you're
reeling in, just get the
fucking thing out of the water.
Let's get out of here, you know?
But he's kind of like,
just kind of sitting there.
He's like oh.
He would have the fish on
the surface, like lingering
to sort of tease the animal.
And I was like, "Get
it out the water!"
And he goes OK, and vroom,
vroom, and we took off
and we left it.
And I often regret, actually--
because it was so close to us
and it circled us.
And I regret that my instinct
was to grab for my phone
and get some video
footage of this thing that
was right next to us.
And in doing that-- I mean,
how often you going to be that
close to a great white shark?
I mean, I've seen them in
fishing boats where they're
like over there or over there.
But in a little Zodiac
where it's right-- like,
you could grab its dorsal fin.
And instead of
experiencing the moment,
I was looking for my phone.
So I really wish that
I hadn't done that.
I really wish that I had
just been present and watched
that thing all the
way around the boat.
But I mean, I saw
it close enough.
But the upshot of this
was, of course, it
didn't encourage me to continue
my abalone diving career.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm sort of a wimp
when it comes to that.
When I go get abalones, I do
a thing called shore picking,
which is also really dangerous.
A lot of people
drown short picking
because you're in water up to
here, so you dive down to go,
and you're kind of under a rock.
And you can get stuck.
And you can drown
in that much water
as easily as you can in 20 feet.
So in any case, that story's in
there, a longer version of it.
PAIGE: Thank you Kirk.
This was really awesome.
KIRK LOMBARD: All right Paige.
And here's my book.
And if you didn't
get one-- also,
I do a monthly
update, if you want
to be on it, where I talk about
when the herring are running
and what fish are happening
in the bay and seafood
and where to get seaweeds
and this kind of stuff.
And if you want to get
on that email list,
it's the door with my lovely
fish wife Camilla over there.
PAIGE: I also have a Sharpie if
you guys want Kirk to sign you
book afterwards too.
KIRK LOMBARD: Yes, I'll
sign your book if you want.
PAIGE: Thank you so
much for [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
KIRK LOMBARD: Thank you.